first of all in a lot of stories there's
a temptation to kind of tell the viewer
how they're supposed to feel about a
certain situation or an arc of a story
but in this you know you're it's left to
you yeah the viewer to make up your mind
to understand was paranoid okay why was
that decision made that way for me it's
because I don't like telling people how
to feel as an artist I just want to
present the facts I'm gonna be truthful
I want to be as honest as I can be I
want to be vulnerable and so if I sit
here and like told you my life story and
I cried and laughed there are things
you're gonna relate to there are things
you're gonna connect with there are
things you might not necessarily relate
to or understand and when you walk away
from it you're gonna have your own
experience of Who I am
yeah and then if I do that tell my life
story again to another person they're
gonna some things they won't relate to
some things they will and then walk away
and have a completely different
understanding of my experience yeah so
that's what I really wanted to do I
wanted to really put all of these types
of experiences like someone who was
religious someone who was not someone
was close their family someone who isn't
someone who wants to leave a mark on the
world and someone who just wants to
exist in it all of those things are
valid but but depending on who comes
into the theatre they will say I agree
with Queen yes you should bend the world
or I agree with slim like you don't have
to do that to matter why do we have to
always be excellent to earn the space
that we keep it's all those I these are
all questions I have and I wrestle with
these I don't have answers I'm just a
person
thinking about these things ruminating
on them and and I want I want to be a
dialog I want someone to come up to me
and say I agree with Clint what Queen
says is right and I go but someone could
argue what slim says is correct and I
love that we're both right no one is
right no one is wrong you know everyone
is valid yeah and every opinion every
thought every action is valid yeah and
that's what I really wanted to feel like
yeah you'd said that um James Frey
approached you with the story and he
said I can't tell it right right what
was that
exchange like what did you feel when he
was like I got this but this is you
gotta tell it well it was like a very
casual exchange that's the crazy thing
like I just came up to me like really
chill out apart
and gave me that opening and I was like
hmm that's interesting and it stayed
with me and I said I was like look man I
want to take that nugget and like go do
something with it and I was like you
know as I'm a fair person I want to
share story by with you but obviously I
wrote it myself but I was like thank you
for that little nugget and I'm gonna
take that and plant that seed and try to
grow this really beautiful black tree
yeah and that's what I think we did but
it was really about something about two
black people killing a cop and surviving
yeah and then going on it just it's did
something to me man I was like I don't
know what that story is I want to tell
it and I want to like tell it I want to
use that story to kind of express and
explain what the black experience is
like and it was really helpful I think
it's easy to say you know Queen and slim
Bonnie and Clyde to make that you know
comparison right would you set it to set
it off well it's where's deal it's it's
it's it's really it's hard to compare to
anything because I haven't seen this
movie before
yeah and so it's a simplistic thing to
say it's the black Bonnie and Clyde said
it off is very different you know
because they decided hey we're gonna go
take we don't go rob something you know
there's nothing these two people are
trying to survive
yeah that's it baby's trying to get home
and and they become sort of these
bystanders and this this sort of like
this revolution and then and that's the
thing like we will create the heroes in
which they need yeah and so queen Aslam
aren't trying to be vigilantes or or
heroes or a symbol of anything but the
people make them that because they need
it yeah they need something to believe
in and that to me is also variants we do
that a time we do that with celebrity
culture it's sort of like why do we
worship service lives like is it because
I oh I want to be that I'm not happy
with who I am and so I want to look up
to this person or I'm mad at this person
for doing this thing because I held him
on a pedestal it's like but we're all
human we're all trying to figure it out
yeah so anyway all those themes that
have came together in the movie because
those are things I'm ruminating on and
always thinking about yeah of all the
questions that the movie asks I think
one of the most important ones is skinny
luthor a fat
true so is it you know what I know my
answer is oh you know what here's the
thing about me I'm a person that I like
I like both eras to be honest there's
some really great moments with bigger
Luther yeah that's a really cool ones
with skinny Luther you know there's one
of my favorite performances if I'm
saying how it's not home and believe at
the Apollo he's in is very thin at that
in that video yeah but there's also so
many help photos of them and video of
him and is more you know plump and yeah
but to me is just the thing that you
know I don't know I was sort of pulling
from this black culture and things we
say to each other it's the soundtrack
the soundtrack is a day one the object
is amazing thank you when never too much
came on to hold the whole crowd
everyone's like you know you you feel
like a little bit that was very
intentional I mean I think Miley and I
wrote some songs in the script on the
page but me Molina really like found it
and I mean it's a little bit of a from
gospel to fail on to Mike Jones to salon
Lauren Hill Lauryn Hill code you know
some new track when he's amazing
for the credits I mean it really we
wanted to take people on a journey
through black music as well yeah and I'm
really grateful to the effect that
people you know groove with us the whole
time yeah yeah it's beautiful
thank you Sam you fulfill thank you so
my real of it